- Le porte-parole du ministère
chinois des Affaires étrangères
tente de se faire rassurant.
"Tous les pays passent par une
période de transitio
La Chine ne fait pas exception.
Actuellement, la situation
épidémique en Chine est tout
à fait prévisible et maîtrisée."
Mais de plus en prérérérérérér.
La Chine est aux prises
avec la pire vage e e COVID-19
en trois ans, alors qu'elle a
laissé tombé sa politique
pepepepepepepepepepepepepepepepi
se retrouvent en détresse,mmmmml
de Tianjin.
Pour réduire le nombre
de visites en personne,
le personnel médical, ici,
en ligne avec les patients.
"J'ai eu 80 rendez-vous
en ueseseseseseseseseseseseseses
se remplissent rapidement",
iqiqiqique cette médecin.
Les États-Unis se disent
préoccupés par le manquechchchct
un test COVID aux voyageursvena,
tout comme l'Italie,
le Japon, l'Inde et Taïwan.
Dre CAROLINE QUACH,
pédiatre, CHU Ste-Justinetststst
d'autres pays parlent d'imposer
dePCPCPCPCPCR à l'entrée;
c'est une possibilité
pour essayer de les trier.
que ceux qui ont été infectés
et qui ont ensnsnsnsns
deux à trois doses de vaccin
sont habituellement
trè
- Il y aurait 37 millions
par jour et les pharmacies
sont frappées par une pénurie
de médicaments. Les en
leur capacité de production
et de distributi
"Cette semaine, la demande
est forte pour les médicaments
contre la toux."
Une équipe spéciale est
de médicaments anti-COVID.
Ici Mélissa Franç